momento de hablar de economía en france
24 por ello me acompaña nuestra
periodista daniela blandón daniela
bienvenida y empezamos hablando de corea
del norte porque a gritos del líder kim
jong-un despidió a su ministro de
economía bueno todos sabemos que el
gobierno de corea del norte es bastante
hermético sin embargo se conocieron en
detalles o imágenes más bien difundidas
por la televisión estatal en las que se
informaba sobre la reunión de esta
semana del gobernante partido de los
trabajadores de kim jong-un en ella se
pudo apreciar a un kim enojado que
señalaba con el dedo y golpeaba el podio
mientras se dirigía a la audiencia la
misma cadena informó que el polémico
líder despidió a su mano derecha en
temas económicos quinto l quien había
sido nombrado apenas en enero a él ya su
gabinete los denunció por lo que llamó
falta de innovación en la elaboración de
los objetivos para su nuevo plan
económico para los próximos cinco años
les digo que habían redactado planes sin
grandes cambios con respecto a los
anteriores vale recordar que a
principios de este
el mismo kim jong-un había reconocido
que su plan económico en los últimos
cinco años había fracasado y hasta le
pidió disculpas a la población por no
haber podido ofrecerle un mejor nivel de
vida
daniela y pasamos a brasil porque él con
el congreso se apresta a discutir un
nuevo plan de ayudas si andrés desde el
31 de diciembre expiró la ayuda mensual
que estaban recibiendo millones de
brasileños para ayudarlos a sortear la
crisis por el kobe de 19 el presidente
del senado rodrigo pacheco dijo que tan
pronto vuelvan de las fiestas de
carnavales es decir la próxima semana
los legisladores comenzarán a trabajar
en el proyecto de ley que extiende esas
ayudas los brasileños de bajos ingresos
comenzaron a recibir un aporte mensual
de 600 reales entre julio y septiembre y
esa cifra bajó a la mitad en los tres
últimos meses del año a 300 reales ahora
el pago podría ser incluso menor y
rondar los 250 reales que son alrededor
de 46 dólares y ahora pasamos a eeuu
porque el empleo no se está recuperando
pero los salarios y cómo es eso andrés y
esta es una clara señal de
desigualdad en eeuu y es que mire de la
pandemia vino afectando a los de más
bajos ingresos esto porque porque según
el departamento de comercio en febrero
de 2020 los estadounidenses ganaron 966
billones de dólares en sueldos
la cifra se llegó a reducir en un 10% en
el primer pico de la pandemia a mediados
del 2020 el más reciente dato disponible
que es el de diciembre ya mostraba que
la cifra volvió a niveles pre pandémicos
de casi 10 billones de dólares y eso qué
quiere decir pues que la pandemia afecta
a los trabajadores de más bajos recursos
porque los ingresos que perdieron esas 9
millones de personas que todavía están
sin empleo se han compensado con los
aumentos salariales que han tenido los
150 millones de ciudadanos que se han
conservado su trabajo daniela porque
varios países podrán seguir enviando
arándanos a eeuu sin restricciones te
voy a contar la historia andrés mir en
septiembre de 2020
washington inició una investigación de
salvaguarda para determinar si las
importaciones de arándanos azules
frescos como congelados habían aumentado
lo suficiente como para amenazar a la
industria en eeuu
esta noticia tuvo con los nervios de
punta países como méxico chile argentina
perú y canadá que son algunos de sus
grandes proveedores de esa fruta hoy
cuatro meses después la comisión de
comercio internacional de eeuu determinó
que no es así dijo no estas compras no
representan ningún daño y por lo tanto
no habrá restricciones como muchos
temían daniela momento de conocer los
indicadores wall street' él sigue
anotando récords a la espera de que el
congreso discuta y apruebe un nuevo plan
de alivio fiscal sus tres principales
índices alcanzaron niveles jamás antes
vistos en europa también subieron las
bolsas impulsadas esta vez por los
precios del petróleo que ya están
alrededor de 60 dólares por barril y en
américa latina hubo ganancias aunque
moderadas en méxico y brasil y cuál es
la cifra del día los 17 millones de
dólares en ganancias y los 94,9 millones
de suscriptores a los que llego disney
en el cuarto trimestre de 2
sus utilidades del segmento de parque se
esfumaron en el año pero están siendo
compensadas de una muy buena manera
desde que decidió esta empresa hacerles
competencia a gigantes del servicio de
streaming como netflix y amazon vídeo
entre otros
daniela hablando con la información
económica muchas gracias por
acompañarnos y ustedes también gracias
por sintonizarnos continúen con toda
nuestra programación
[Música]